une évasion réussie dépendent trois
choses connaître / tout savoir sur la
routine et une aide à l'extérieur ou à
l'intérieur
ray breslin et capables de se parler de
n'importe quelle prise on pense par
l'homme nous testons un prototype de
pénitencier pour les criminels dont plus
aucun gouvernement ne veut entendre
parler
ceux qui financent le projet veulent
s'assurer qu'on ne peut pas s'évader de
ces lieux le contact sur place le
directeur s'appelle roger marche on
commence quand on a commencé
bienvenue dans votre nouvelle demeure
je suis directeur hop hop ce que le
directeur marché
il n'y a pas de directeur marche avec
mon époque on aura besoin barrez vous
qu'est ce que tu faisais avant de
débarquer ici mon boulot c'est de mai
venez de présenta pas l'air aussi mal tu
tes voeux ceux qui ont payé pour que tu
sois ici tu voles que tu es reste à guy
rey a franchi la grille mme kokott le
tombeau tirer quelque part c'est ici coi
si on m'a tendu un piège quelqu'un veut
m'enterrer je vais découvrir qui est je
vais découvrir pourquoi je marche
faudrait faire diversion que tu frappes
comme un végétarien qu'est-ce qui m'a
dit qu il prépare une évasion
je ne vais rien remettez serra dans leur
cage sort pas dit si je te dis ce bonne
guerre
dites à ceux qui m'ont enfermé ici je
vais réduire cette prison en cendres